i don't even know how to sum up our
previous segment but denise has been
sleeping in her living room for 10 years
now so that waverly could have her own
room and i'm so excited to show them and
reveal
their new living room so are you ready
yeah
all right let's do this here we go come
on
open her
[Applause]
it's
up
[Music]
totally different right
yes
i can't even believe it wow
it's so beautiful i noticed that it's
like a real living room
it's like
i noticed that you really lightened and
brightened it up too yeah you know what
i felt like it was kind of cave like
right yeah yeah kinda yeah so we wanted
to lighten it up obviously like with the
walls that we're looking at right here
wanted to keep it neutral but then i
wanted to give you like a little punch
of color so drew i think you'll
recognize this wallpaper that we have
right here right i made that wallpaper
wow
yeah so that's one of those things i
think that really elevates the space but
you know what the best part about this
entire room we can create it in less
than a thousand dollars unbelievable
thousand dollars and let me show you how
honestly the biggest thing is like
thrifting we all know that thrifting and
repurposing is the best way to get the
most bang for your buck for instance
this couch right here
less than 300 dollars let me see as a
matter of fact like drew sit on this i
just want you to touch this thing
this is vegan leather
so how does it feel so awesome
so much better
and then in terms of like storage i know
drew is a huge fan on storage everything
has to double yes yes oh yeah so unlike
your other coffee table now this coffee
table actually lifts up so you can put
all the tv remotes all of the blankets
you can get everything yeah yes how do
you close it nicole do you know so they
have a little uh mechanism lock here and
then this just goes down once we unlatch
it now another thing when we talk about
storage look over here now you have all
of this storage and organization the
biggest thing was using that vertical
space now we have lots of shelves lots
of baskets and that gives you that
opportunity to hide all of that clutter
and now everything looks like purposeful
and i think that's the biggest thing
right now making it functional and
purposeful all at the same time fabulous
i also love that you chose to do a
workspace because with homework and
school
and you know work this way you have a
functional space where you can sit but
also get things done
um i love that you went with the
romantic florals macale i think that's
really beautiful there are just pops
absolutely it's also just
the neutral color palette that you chose
as opposed to
the dark is sort of browns and navies
those were the tones i was getting and
this feels much fresher yes and lighter
and speaking of light did you see your
two new lights so now you have overhead
lighting here and then additionally we
have your task lamp which is over to the
right that i found at the thrift shop so
it's like perfect just to kind of
brighten the space up even more
one tip i have also if you're ordering
um online is a lot of sites including
cherished yes will have a filter
bar and you go under it and you do
within 25 miles which you know
that you can pick up very easily or
they're not going to charge you for
shipping you can even do within 50 miles
if that makes sense to you and you
totally avoid the shipping costs and you
know you can just go pick it up it's as
if it's in a store nearby you and that
can eradicate hundreds of dollars and
delays
so that's a really helpful tip when
you're filtering through these vintage
sites i just can't thank you enough
mikael for bringing up the space and
freshening up i could never have done
that
thank you
thank you so much
you're gonna love it
[Music]